la gauche a visiblement la volonté de ne
pas voter le texte global à l'issue du
temps qui est bien imparti on a jusqu'au
12 mars à minuit vous craignez que
finalement il y a pas de de vote globale
mais ça serait dommage pour tout le
monde et je dis ça j'ai pas le sentiment
en le disant d'être en contradiction
avec ce que disent même les syndicats
c'était ému et ils avaient été peiné du
fait qu'on puisse même pas avoir le
débat sur l'article 7 qui est
effectivement important puisque c'est
celui ou notamment on discute de
l'allongement de la durée de de
cotisation c'est ça la démocratie c'est
de pouvoir en transparence devant nos
concitoyens dire ce pourquoi on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord ça doit être ça
le débat donc moi je souhaite
effectivement qu'il puisse aller au bout
je pense que c'est possible je pense
encore que c'est possible en tout cas le
gouvernement fera tout pour elle sera à
disposition des parlementaires pour
avancer débattre et enrichir le texte un
autre souci qui se pose à vous au
gouvernement c'est que en cas de
sortie du du Sénat vote ou pas votre
d'ailleurs il y aura une commission
liste paritaire un retour à l'Assemblée
nationale et bon pour le coup moi j'ai
fait les comptes et à l'heure actuelle
vous n'avez pas de majorité pour voter
ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale j'en
sais rien vous êtes peut-être plus
spécialiste
285 selon mes comptes et évidemment on
discute avec je dirais chaque
parlementaire parce que là aussi il faut
être sincère et transparent moi je pense
que c'est très important c'est les
débats qui sont parfois difficiles parce
que c'est un texte c'est un texte
d'effort qui est pas un texte
majoritairement populaire dans l'opinion
donc tout ça on le regarde extrêmement
près
je vous réponds là-dessus mais nous
notre objectif c'est de bâtir une
majorité
au Parlement non mais l'objectif voter
ce texte je comprends je vous réponds le
plus précisément possible que c'est
faisable notre objectif depuis le début
c'est de faire adopter ce texte et de le
faire adopter 149-3 là aussi je vous
réponds la façon la plus transparente
possible mais ça parle de la majorité je
vous réponds dans l'ordre de vos
questions je pense que notre majorité
sera unie pour voter le texte